Next question. When I had cavitation surgery, they said in bone and found that I had a parasite.
No one ever gave me anything to kill it. So I finally decided to run the six-hour parasite
rife frequency today. Could this make me incredibly tired today?
Yes, yep. So if you run a kill program, so if you're running a kill program
on the rife, then what's a kill program? Well, kill program is anything for a pathogen.
So you're running a viral program, not usually a viral program, but bacteria or
parasite, fungus, things like that. If you're running a kill program, especially it's
even worse if you're running a gram negative bacteria like live disease. But if
you're running a kill program, I tell you, the rife works and it will kill these
things. And when single cell organisms are killed, so there's parasites that are
multicell organism parasites like worms and but most parasites that are going to be like in your
mouth and things like that are going to be single cell parasites. When you kill single
cell organisms, you're going to liberate a lot of endotoxins. We need waste because it
just causes cell lysis to sell the organism just basically explodes and just makes a mess
from a microscopic sense. And then your body's got to get rid of those things. And they have
to detoxify through your kidneys and liver. And you can overwhelm your kidneys and liver
and then you feel yucky. So yes, you feel that's what a herc cyber reaction is, is when your
liver pathways are overwhelmed, then you just feel exhausted. So it's kind of your
body's way to kind of shut you down and slow you down. You're parasympathetics are hypersimulated,
try to get rid of this stuff and you just need to go rest. And put a hot pack over your
liver to help decrease the viscosity of your bile to help bile flow. Use a castoral pack
over your liver, do a coffee and all those things would be helpful in this kind of scenario.